the Joe Rogan experience you know what I
think and this is just one of the time I
think this sometime I'm not married to
this but I think that you have the
possibility to occasionally get these
glimpses of maybe senses that are
evolving in human beings and you can
call it intuition you can call it some
connection you have with someone
especially with someone you really love
like your family or loved ones or
someone you really care about and you
think about them and then they call it's
almost like Mans is there was some sort
of a connection between people that just
comes in and out it goes into night like
sometimes you're thinking about someone
they text you like is that just total
coincidence it might be but it also
might be that there's some weird hard to
define impossible to measure connection
that we all share with each other I
think it's a beautiful way to look at it
I thought about that one day when I was
just you know thinking about my dad I
was traveling and it made me think about
thoughts and how thoughts are almost
like messages we send out into the
universe to just let somebody else know
they're not alone and maybe they grab
them through some ways through some
realm or portal and it's it's important
to like conversation is so important
because of that because it makes you it
reminds you of things and you draw
associations I was talking about my
father one day and you know John Heffron
yeah sure he sent me a message and it
was well my dad was sick and I was just
you know very upset about it and John
was just like you know I went through
the same thing that you did I want to
let you know that like hearing is one of
the last senses to go when people are
sick so just so you know that your dad
can still hear you and I had been afraid
to call my dad during this whole process
because I didn't want to know what he
had forgotten and so I John sent me that
message on a Sunday and because he sent
me that message it made me think about
my dad and I was like you know what I
haven't called him and so long I'm just
gonna call him tonight it was like four
o'clock in the morning East Coast time
he was in his um you know the the what
is it like Hospice is what's the last
place that people go is it like the
nursing home is usually like right
before people are passing I think it's
like a nursing home
well nursing home certainly
our place for a lot of people yeah I
think that's he went from memory care
facility to the nursing home and I
called the night nurse and my dad
couldn't talk at that point but because
I said something and John thought about
it and sent me this DM I never met him
before and that DM made me want to call
my dad and I called the night nurse it
was like 4 o'clock in the morning and in
Syracuse New York and I go I know my dad
can't hear me right now but can you just
tell him that I love him and I'm
thinking about him and and I've Karen I
think her name was she said sure I can
go in and I'll tell him I'll whisper
into his ear and that's about 4 o'clock
and you know about what was at 1 o'clock
here whatever the time difference is and
so I fell asleep my sister calls me
about 20 minutes later my dad passed
away right after the nurse went in to
tell him that and I can consider that a
coincidence sure we can chalk it up to a
coincidence or it could be what you're
speaking about where there is some sort
of deep connection that we have that we
can't express or articulate with words
even though these words that were sent
to me are the thing that motivated me to
talk to my dad there's something to the
effect that there maybe there's
something mystical going on maybe
there's something that we're not meant
to explain the problem is the word
mystical the problem is that we're
looking at it like it's some sort of a
magic thing we're calling [ __ ]
because so many people pretend to have
it and don't and there's no real science
to sort of back it up just zero
yeah and there's also been like the
amazing Randi has put out a reward where
James Randi I think it's a million
dollars if you can prove any psychic
ability no one's been able to win it
well how do you prove I don't do things
of the brain you'd have to do it through
well here's the thing if it is let's
just let's just go wild here we need
merging he would never allow this he
would cut this off he would entertain it
and with a scientific perspective but if
you're looking at something like an
emerging characteristic of human beings
like for instance like we know that we
used to be single-celled organisms it's
very unlikely that during time we were
single-celled organisms like rock or we
could feel or we could do interpretive
dance okay no one was writing books and
are single-celled organisms so as these
single-celled organisms come
multi-celled organisms become human
beings like things are getting more and
more
flex and more and more skills and more
and more senses and more and more of an
ability to manipulate their environment
and I think that it's only it only makes
sense that it there there could be some
non-local connection that we have to
each other some way without just
touching or talking or through visual
there's some sort of a connection that
we have with each other that we just
haven't evolved yet it's on the way it's
coming it's coming and that's why we
long for it that's why we're really
interested in psychics we're really
interested in palm people that know the
feet not just because we want to know
what the future is we want some sort of
a feeling of hope and interconnectivity
but it's not it's not just that it's
also that I think we know there's
something to it
once we know there's something there's
something grander beyond just this
physical existence that we have and then
it brings up the whole conversation
about the creation or existence an
introduction of consciousness
consciousness when does that come into
the picture when did it come into the
picture when was the first thing
conscious and what is consciousness is
it just sentient this is just being
aware and looking out for yourself
because then dear conscious our rats
conscious because it seems they're
pretty conscious too it seems like
they're I think there's a spectrum to
consciousness and I think the one that
we're talking about is the beyond you
know that like consciousness that next
level where it's got to go somewhere
right it's got to go somewhere I mean
look at our brains our brains are these
our brains are like a universe and of
itself and it's there in the darkness
until death I mean you can't even
there's no way to really besides like
graphs and everything to really
understand the workings of the brain
I mean it's firing all this
electricity's going off and these little
teeny molecules are doing jobs and
there's like we said earlier sometimes
it works great sometimes it's dogs yeah
it's really why a person it's really
it's it's so it's so crazy and then
there's like this thing that happens in
the brain and in the body this like
immune response where they send out this
molecule it's almost like a Paul Revere
of molecules where it lets all the other
our molecules in the body know that some
shits about to go down it's like you
know it's like a it's like you know a
warning right like adrenaline response
yeah but like the little teeny there's
actually little microscopic things that
are doing these jobs yeah whoo what the
[ __ ] how do they start their day right
are they waking up like Joe Rogan and
going working out for an hour
you don't even know they're there no you
don't even know that's why I [ __ ]
talked to him bro dude I get it
[Applause]